hey guys i'm curly i'm jasmine and we're
here for queer prom 2018
in new york city and we're about to go
meet the court let's go
[Music]
hello hey tiara how's it going hi i'm
great well i wanted to introduce to my
friend who had some news for you hi
oh my god how are you oh my god what
oh my god so we wanted to tell you that
you were selected and you are coming to
new york to go to the basketball
prom oh my god you feel like i came out
to myself when i was like
10. i was like 10 years old like
okay like i want to say this why can't i
say it
people are telling me i shouldn't be
saying something like this people are
telling me i shouldn't feel this way
so i didn't feel comfortable enough to
share how i was feeling and so it made
me i guess it made me a really angry
person
my um my father is
um something he's very one of those
people that's like
you know um my kids are queer so
i love queer people and he says things
like
oh you wanna you wanna act like a man
then i'm gonna treat you like i'm gonna
talk to you like you're a man so
you better man up you better do this and
just because i identify
as a trans guy doesn't mean i gotta be
super masculine because i'm
i'm not hi
so i'm in my room it's late at night and
i just
realized that there's only five days
until queer pro living in philly is many
different things it's
it's really cool to be around music
creators but at the same time the people
who i like to surround myself with
sometimes
don't like me to be around them which
can suck
[Music]
i spend a lot of time in the music scene
in philly and it gets kind of scary
it's kind of upsetting because a lot of
the music business is homophobic and
transphobic
and sexist and horrible
i had my sister at home and she was much
more of a support system
she is like she's probably the only
person
who i know that's always always
supported me like
my whole life well for me i'm already
queer
i came out as pansexual a long time ago
and like everybody wasn't accepting of
it you came out twice though
twice you came out twice yeah i guess it
happened
you came out twice but when you came out
as gay first i was just like okay
i know like okay
and then the second time you were just
like i'm transgender and i'm like all
right
like what's your name what are your
preferred pronouns
all right that's fine
i came out to my mom in a 7-eleven
parking lot
[Music]
we were fighting i think over i think
like transgender
rights or something and i was like well
mom i'm gay
i then i ran out the car went 7-11
went back to the car and we stayed there
crying for at least an hour
oh the 711 people probably think we're
crazy but i'm so sorry
yeah i love my mom i wish she was here
so we're getting ready to abort our
flight to new york for buzzfeed's queer
prom honey avelina is my only niece
and she is the same age as my daughter
eva it means everything to
be able to be here for your mom who
loves you
so much and even though she's in
nashville excuse me
award i am texting her like crazy and
sending her pictures and she's here with
you every minute and we love you
how has me being gay affected our
relationship
um i think we're closer now
i think um you've been allowed
are able to open up more man
um which is a good thing it's a good
thing
yeah it's taken me a long time to be
able to say i have a girlfriend
out loud because all the repercussions
that can happen in high school and like
the cruelty of like kids and i honestly
wanted to protect her more than myself
so i didn't want her to go through
like what i've gone through through the
past like in my past um
it was hard because i i liked her
a little bit you know and it was hard
not being able to like
show like our love and affection out in
public in a safe than a place that's
supposed to be safe like a high school
dance
i don't feel protected as a queer person
especially as a queer person of color
i think at my school specifically for
the number of
out queer and trans people that we have
there's very little protection in terms
of enumerated policy
i've arguably done more work for lgbt
inclusivity at my school
than some of the people who make the
policies at my school who it's their
literal job to do this work
and so it's it's been frustrating
[Music]
ohio is it's quaint it's one of those
places where everyone thinks it's just
corn there's also like a lot of racism
and homophobia
in addition to corn when i came out i
didn't have an official guys like
i'm queer i just started dating a girl
and everyone was like oh i didn't know
you were gay and i'm like well i'm not
and they're like what are you and i'm
like haven't figured it out yet
i think in terms of coming out as gender
non-binary
that was a little bit more difficult i
got more of
well i don't know what that means what
can you explain that to me well
are you sure that there's more than two
genders and i think people get caught up
on the pronouns like oh the different
pronouns it's not grammatically correct
um in reality like they're not seeing a
person saying like hey
i'm different than what you think i am i
need you to accept that mom
how do you feel about me going to
buzzfeed's queer prom
happy for you i'm glad you got picked
because i know that was something that
you really wanted
i've learned a lot and um
jose has really made me think about my
life
and um
um here it comes
[Music]
high school was really difficult
i thought that i had it rough because i
was the nerd in school
i was mistreated by people but
they just they really did all say wrong
really wrong
and i'm sorry i'm sorry that you had to
go through that
for reference school was hard because
we'd have teachers that are like
we're trying to find a different class
for jose to be in because you know they
make the teacher uncomfortable
or we understand that this teacher makes
you uncomfortable because they don't
represent your identity but
you know we're not going to do anything
about it and they've been like oh we're
going to suspend you
like oh we're going to put you in
detention and we're going to like switch
your schedule and like
never getting to the root of the problem
and
so yeah i really appreciate my mom
yeah and you can be yourself and turn up
turn up yeah okay i'll do that i'll turn
it okay
okay so there's only like three days
left until i go to new york
i've i've never flown and now here i am
graduating
flying out to new york like what a way
to start you know adulthood
my name's paige i'm 18 years old and i
come from las vegas nevada
i came out to my aunt she was my support
system i told her everything
that's where i would go to escape from
my situation at home she's like that
backbone that i needed
growing up so i questioned my
grandmother and my aunt
actually those are the first two people
i questioned i was like what is a
lesbian
because like i was like what is that
like because that's what i was told that
i was
and i was like yeah i like girls there's
a term for it
so when i came out that weekend after
like sitting there and contemplating
a 12 year old sitting on the couch just
like okay
i i went up back upstairs and i said you
know what you're right
i'm i i am hey hey hey hey sydney oh you
caught me in deep thought
i went to elementary school middle
school and high school with the same
kids so everyone just grew up knowing
each other
we don't have a lgbt
club we did and they got rid of it
when they got rid of it i was kind of
disappointed i was like
you're serious right you can't do that
you're basically telling us we can't
express ourselves
so i grew up my junior year and senior
year without one
and you just saw this decline of people
who didn't want to be as open about it
at school and we just didn't have the
club anymore
i was born in boston i lived there for
my first two years of my life and then
i moved to barbados
part of going up there was it's a in the
culture it's not
you know okay to be who i was so
it was a very very private part of my
life i moved back when i was 10
years old my school was an all-boys
new england prep school so
take without what you will it's
predominantly white predominantly
straight so
there wasn't much of a community for two
aspects of my identity so
it became difficult to really exist in
that space so that's when i turned to
theater after my freshman year it's
something that i ended up really
enjoying and it became a huge part of my
life
[Music]
i have some news yeah well we're super
excited that you're gonna come hang with
us
and i love your story we're so stoked
so you're good to go like you can come
you're free
and you're going to bring your mom right
yeah
and she can come i wish i had told my
mom first
because that's the only opinion that i
really cared about i remember the story
very very distinctly december 6 2017
we were talking about one of my friends
who was going through a really horri
like a
difficult time in her life and um i was
asking my mom with for
advice on how i could help her and help
her through this time
and she was talking about how oh i just
like i wish
kids would feel more comfortable telling
their parents things so i was like oh
this might be a sign let me just do it
right now and it was the longest pause
ever and it finally said it and she
laughed and was like i know
i knew i i i
just knew i am happy that he is able to
you know
come out his comfort zone and and um
and say who he really is not being a
shame
and um being free
uh i respect that a lot about him
yeah i went to farm i went to prom twice
and i was was a
like a singular person that i liked in a
space full of people that made me
uncomfortable
like if i wanted to bring um like a boy
or something like that i don't think
there would be space for me to do that
do i go do i get judged
i don't want that judgment on my
shoulders
it was ugly that's unfortunate i'm sorry
about that
i lived i survived that day you're here
now
i made it i have i have a good
prom coming queen
i'm so excited to meet them okay
i'm here at buzzfeed like holy crap like
this is amazing surprise
it's just an adrenaline rush it's like
whoa we have a little surprise for you
we got some new little phones for you
guys
so these phones will be so y'all can
document the queer prom
and then also y'all can take them home
afterward
i don't think anyone understands how
excited i am to be here
i think at queer problem i'm most
excited about the energy i never feel
like i can just
go and socialize somewhere and i feel
like it's gonna be a place where i can
just talk to anybody and then be like
hey what's up
i think this is the first time that i
would probably be in a room with that
many people
who are queer exciting i'm so excited to
just click with everybody and
run around and touch everything touch
everything if it's shiny i'm touching it
all right everybody make a silly face
three two one
[Music]
[Music]
fish you